hey guys it is thursday the twenty
eighth of january today my name is jeff
mcdonald and you are watching games
bunnies yay have said they're on a
journey to regain the trust of the pc
gamer starting with origin access while
senior marketing director peter o'reilly
neglected to mention precisely where the
company suspects they fell short
possibilities may include the messy
online only sim city and the sims for
lacking a number of fan favorite
features at launch o'reilly explained at
EA are now doing their best to turn this
around he told MCV over the last couple
of years we have focused on ensuring a
great play experience from launch and
bringing players a better experience on
origin with programs like the great game
guarantee on the house and now origin
access EA plans to add more non EA games
to the origin access library in future
there are currently 15 games on the
subscription service and only this war
of mine is from a third party publisher
comparatively on xbox one EA access
beaches known on EA games presumably
because that wouldn't really make a
whole lot of sense with the name OMG has
had some personnel shuffling today as
Pete Parsons is now set to take over as
CEO from Harold Ryan Bungie revealed the
news on their website where they said
the board of directors appointed Parsons
proof in the company coo since 2002
Parsons seemed are pretty excited about
the whole CEO deal and as far as destiny
ghost he explained I want you to know
that my number one priority and bungees
is a doll it has been to deliver great
games that we can all share together I
believe the destiny is a one-of-a-kind
experience I also believe you've yet to
see a sku year's best work my new role
here the studio will be entirely focused
on fulfilling that promise it's
currently unclear as to why Ryan step
down or whether he will remain with
honey i really hope you aren't getting
sick of hearing about expansion to the
games that aren't out yet because the
division is getting three of them as is
the state of the games industry Ubisoft
has announced their post launch plans
for the shooter free launch the three
paid expansion will include underground
where you can check out the underworld
of New York City survival where you'll
have to stay alive as long as possible
while fending off a number of attackers
and last and which is presently not
detailed these expansions will be
releasing periodically over the course
of the year while Ubisoft are also
planning a series of free updates for
the game if you buy the dlc you'll also
get some new weapons outfits skins and
monthly benefits including exclusive
content drop and special events for the
detailed pricing information and
specific release date hasn't been
devolved at this date let me know down
in that comment section how you feel
about the divisions DLC plans and hit
the games that we've got stories undying
like fiancée and insomniac new game that
is everything I help you today but do be
sure to pop by same time tomorrow we'll
have the top five stories out the entire
week I would catch you this
you